so what i need is actually a way to
estimate the test error
for each of these models m0 m1 m2 all
the way through mp
so that i can choose among them
and basically in order to estimate the
test error i have two approaches and one
approach is that i can indirectly
estimate the test error by somehow
computing the training error and then
adjusting it
and the idea behind this adjustment is
that if i can somehow adjust the
training error to account for the bias
due to overfitting
then that can give me
an estimate of of
test error that's again based on the
training error but somehow looks more
like a test error
and the alternative approach is that i
can try to directly estimate the test
error
and i can do that using some of the
approaches that are in chapter five of
this book
um and and those involve either cross
validation or a validation set approach
and so so that's a really direct
approach to estimating the test error
where i fit models on part of the data
and then i evaluate them on a holdout
set
so we're now going to talk about both of
these approaches
so cp aic bic and adjusted r squared all
adjust the training error in order to
give us an estimate of the test error
and and they all can be used to select
among models with different numbers of
variables
so we're now going to look at a figure
showing us cp bic and adjusted r squared
for the best model of each size that we
get using best subset selection on the
credit data so we're first going to look
at this figure and then we'll talk about
how these quantities are defined
so again this is on the credit data
example
and on the x-axis here we have the
number of predictors in each of these
figures
and on the y-axis we have cp
bic which stands for bayesian
information criterion and adjusted r
squared and again we'll define all three
of these quantities in a minute but the
idea is roughly speaking we want these
quantities to be small so we prefer a
model in which cp bic and
are as small as possible and actually i
misspoke we want adjusted r squared to
be as large as possible
so if i look at the shape of this curve
i can see that um cp is minimized
when we look at the model with six
predictors
bic is smallest when we look at the
model with four predictors
and adjusted r squared is smallest when
we look at a model with six predictors
again
so that suggests that we should use
somewhere between four and six
predictors
and actually if we look at these figures
a little more closely we can see that
basically these curves are more or less
flat after we get to around three or
four predictors
and so on the base of these these
figures i would say you know i really
don't think we need more than three or
max four predictors to do a good
prediction on this credit data
so you know and i've scribbled all over
the slide oops
on this picture it's hard to see here
but actually the curve is going up right
as we go to the right despite the fact
it's it's flat that's right yes i like
the rss exactly it's a little hard to
see yeah but this is slightly increasing
it's smallest with four predictors and
then it goes up a little bit but you
know i don't really think that there's
compelling evidence here that that four
is really better than three or better
than five so if it were me you know i
think simpler is always better so i'd
probably choose a model with you know
three predictors maximum four predictors
yeah i agree
great so now we're going to talk about
on malocp
and once again this is an adjustment to
the training r squared the the training
rss that gives us an estimate for the
test rss and it's defined in this
formula so let's say we're looking at a
model with d
predictors
um so then we're going to calculate the
rss for that model with g predictors and
we're going to add to the rss 2 times d
where again d is the number of
predictors times sigma hat squared where
sigma hat squared is an estimate of the
variance associated with each error
epsilon
in the linear model
and so the idea is we can calculate cp
for those models m0 m1 m2 through mp
that we were looking at a few minutes
ago and we can just choose the model
with the smallest cp
so like if we're looking at the model m3
then that model contains three
predictors and an intercept
so that model has d equals four
and we can calculate the rss for the
model m3 and we just calculate sigma hat
squared there's a formula for that
it gives us a cp
and out of all these models m0 to mp
we're just going to choose the one for
which the cp is smallest because that's
the one that we believe is going to have
the smallest test set rss now just to
clarify a bit about the sigma hat
squared first of all if if p is bigger
than n we're going to have a problem
right because
what typically sigma hat squared the
same values the same estimates used for
all models being compared so you usually
do is you fit the full model all p
predictors and you take the mean square
residual for that model to give you
sigma hat squared
um so that's the way you do it of course
that's going to create a problem p is
bigger than n because that full model
was not defined and the error will be
zero
so already we see that cp is restricted
to cases where you've got n bigger than
p
that's right
and even if p is close to n you're going
to have a problem because you're asking
the sigma squared might be
far too low
so
so that's malo's cp
and then another very closely related
idea is called the aic criterion so the
the aic stands for a keiki information
criterion akaiki was the name of the guy
who came up with this idea
and the way that this is defined is
negative 2 log l plus 2 times d where d
is once again the number of predictors
in the model that i'm looking at so for
m3 d equals 4
and now capital l here is the maximized
value of the likelihood function for the
estimated model
so this looks a little bit complicated
and in fact it's written in this very
general way
because aic is a quantity that we can
calculate for many different model types
not just linear models but also logistic
regression and so on
but it turns out that in the case of a
linear model
negative 2 log l
is just equal to rss
over sigma hat squared
so if you look at that and you plug in
rss over sigma hat squared for negative
2 log l then what you realize is that
aic
and mallow cp are actually proportional
to each other
and since we're just going to choose the
model for which
cp is smallest that's equivalent to
choosing the model for which aic is
smallest
so so aic and cp are actually really the
same thing for linear models but for
other types of models
these things are not the same and aic is
a good approach
so we've talked about cp and aic
and another very related idea here is
the bic where b stands for bayesian so
this is the bayesian information
criterion and it's like the aic and the
this malocp but it comes from sort of a
bayesian argument
and once again we've got a very similar
formula we calculate the residual sum of
squares
and then we add an adjustment term which
is the log of the number of observations
times d which is once again the number
of predictors in the model i'm looking
at
so like m3 since it has three predictors
and intercept m three has d equals four
and once again sigma hat squared is an
estimate of the error variance which may
or may not be available depending on
whether n is greater than p or less than
p
and so once again with bic we're
estimating the test set rss
or rather the average test at rss across
the observations
and so we want it to be
as
small as possible so we're going to
choose the model with the smallest bic
so what's the difference between bic and
aic
well remember aic
it had it would look just like this but
in aic this term was actually 2d sigma
hat squared right
so the only difference between aic and
bic is the choice of log n versus two
bic has this log n here
and um
and aic has a 2.
and so in general
if n is greater than 7
then log n is greater than 2.
and so what that means is that if you
have more than seven observations in
your data
bic is going to put more of a penalty
on a large model and in other words bic
is going to tend to choose smaller
models than aic is
so so bic is going to give you the
selection of models that have fewer
variables than either cp or or aic
so we see that these three ideas bic cp
and aic are really almost identical they
just have slightly different formulas
they all we want to minimize them and
they all require an estimate
for sigma hat squared which again is not
available necessarily
if it's only going to be available if n
is greater than p
so the last of these approaches that i'm
going to talk about that sort of
indirectly adjusts the training error to
get an estimate of the test error is the
adjusted r squared and so
we saw in chapter 3
the idea of the r squared and remember r
squared was defined just as a little
refresher
r squared is defined as 1 minus the
residual sum squared
divided by the total sum of squares
where
in case we need a reminder the total sum
of squares
is just the
sum of y i minus y bar squared so y bar
is the average response y i is the ith
response and we're just taking the sum
of those squared values
and so this was the r squared and as
we've as we know a big r squared
indicates a model that really fits the
data well but unfortunately you can't
compare models by just taking the you
can compare models of different sizes by
just taking the one with the biggest r
squared because you can't compare the r
squared of a model with three variables
to the r squared of a model with eight
variables for instance
so the adjusted r squared tries to fix
this and the way that it does that is
that it makes you pay a price for having
a large model so the idea is adjusted r
squared adjusts the r squared so that
the values that you get are comparable
even if the numbers of predictors are
different
so the way that it does this is by
adding a denominator
to the
to rss and to tss in this ratio so in so
instead of just taking 1 minus rss over
tss
we take 1 minus rss over n minus d minus
1
divided by tss over n minus 1
where again d is the number of variables
in the model that we're considering
and so basically the idea here
is that when d is large
this denominator is really large
and so you're dividing the rss by a
really big number and you're going to
end up with a smaller r squared
so so what's happening is that we're
going to pay a price for having a large
model in the adjusted r squared
unlike the classical r squared which
where we know pay no price for having a
large model with a lot of features
so
the adjusted r squared we want it to be
large
if it's large then that indicates a
model that really fits the data well
and again the idea is that adjusted r
squared is something that we can
actually compare in a meaningful way
regardless of the number of predictors
in the model some of this notice looks
like you can it doesn't it doesn't
require an estimate of sigma squared
that's good and you can also apply it
when p is bigger than n yeah that's
right so that's a really nice advantage
of
of rss as rob said we don't need to
estimate sigma squared which can be a
problem
and in principle we can apply it when p
is larger than n
so um
we want a large value of adjusted r
squared
and
and so the adjusted r squared in
practice people really like it it tends
to work really well so some
statisticians don't like it as much as
um cp aic and bic
and the reason is because it sort of
works well empirically but some
statisticians feel that it doesn't kind
of have the theoretical backing of some
other approaches what do you think of
that rob
that's that's true there is a bias in
our field towards things which have more
theory behind them um and i guess is
this a example of that but one nice
thing about adjusted r squared is like
if you're working with um someone who's
not a statistician
like
scientists who aren't statisticians are
really familiar with r squared and so
from when to understand r squared
adjusting r squared is just a really
small one off and it's kind of easier to
explain to someone in a certain sense
than a ic cp or bic and so that's one
really nice thing about it
but adjusted r squared you can't really
generalize to other types of models so
if you have like logistic regression you
can't do this so you'll see in the next
section we'll talk about cross
validation which is uh our our favorite
method
which you can generalize and one major
advantage is you don't need to know d so
the the d in in this method
in in adjusted r squared and cp and aic
is the number of parameters but in some
methods like ridge regression and the
lasso which we'll also talk about
again in a few minutes
the value of d is not even known so we
can't apply any of these methods but
cross-validation can still be applied
yeah that's true so like in this whole
discussion i've been talking about least
squares models and then i've been
occasionally mentioning logistic
regression but i could have some totally
crazy model that i come up with that
like is like something that nobody's
ever seen before and it would be totally
hopeless to to apply an aic type of idea
to it or an adjusted r squared type of
idea but i can always perform cross
validation or the validation set
approach no matter how wacky my model is
and that's actually a really nice thing
about those two approaches